hey what's up my name's samuel leeds
right now i'm standing outside a house
that was bought for sixty thousand
pounds now there's houses in the street
that are selling for a hundred thousand
pounds
how was it bought so cheap because it
needs work doing on it however the work
needed on it are actually very very
small i'm going to show you around this
is a perfect example
of a buy refurbished refinance property
so this was kind of like a joint venture
between
our driver yeah awesome so
and the thing is as well like this
property
what what did you bring to the table tom
what are you getting on this deal so
i brought ten thousand pounds that i'd
saved the deal and then
also a lot of hours uh working on the
property helping doing the refurb okay
so you put 10 grand in yeah you put 50
grand in yeah
so all together 60 000 pounds yes what's
the vision what's the what was the plan
with it with it now
okay so we're hoping that we'll get the
property finished off
we'll get it revalued um we're hoping to
revalue it
for 85 90 000. we've spent 10 000 pounds
on it
and then we'll pull our money out and
get it rented
for 600 to 650 a month and this is not
something that you're new to either is
it
no i've been in property since 2003 and
have a large portfolio
what sort of extend is your portfolio i
think we've got um
between ourselves and we also have a
little
letting agency that uh we manage
properties for other landlords mostly
that we've sourced for
yeah um so we've got about 100 tenants
that we're looking after
fantastic that's incredible so tom you
put
10 grand in all i'm trying to work out
is how does an 18 year old
have penguin did your parents like give
you that 10 grand and then you invested
it
so it came for a lot of hours working so
i worked a
qualified swimming teacher that's about
100 pounds a week a lot of hours a lot
of effort
yeah and then i also get paid to play
rugby as well i'm in an academy the
local academy for the huddersfield
giants
and i saved all my money from there as
well so you've been saving for a long
time
since i was born since you were born
show me around the house
hey how are you doing all right so work
work's still happening
yeah works getting close to finished
yeah so so tom
you basically your mom said you know
look you're responsible for sorting
everything out
so we spent 750 pounds on the kitchen
and then we
paid 450 pounds to get it fitted 750
pounds
yeah that sounds kind of cheap yeah
where did you get the kitchen from so we
bought the kitchen on ebay for money and
chef
your boyfriend this is what happens when
you get when you get an 18 year old on
the job right they're like yeah you know
so you bought it from ebay i thought how
does this would be okay
but yeah right how much for the house
could you be reckoning like
and then to fit so you've got it for 750
450 to fit it yeah and there's a lot of
kitchen
units here yeah
but you've been just with the manual
work as well you've been like stripping
the wallpaper
yeah stripping the wallpaper i had to
take all the
interior doors off for the new interior
doors nice
um have to take all the tiles off
upstairs in the bathroom you know what
though
you're in this project because your
mom's seeing what you're doing with some
other stuff you've got a rent to rent
going on you've got
so it's like it's a nice joint venture
yeah you know and although he's your son
you're not giving him any money no he's
he's
bringing value i'm kind of jealous i
know it's a good deal when i'm like
jealous of
the deal huddersfield market interesting
this is the first three bedrooms yeah
what happened up here
okay so after we bought it it was all
fine
we're um halfway through the refurb
and there was a lot of rain and we got a
little leak
oh so uh that has now been fixed what
did you
do what did you have to do to put this
rock literally just um
a slate moving and a bit of gutter
patching problem with the roof
fix that oh that's good okay how much
does that cost
like about 110 pounds or something yeah
that's the thing if you think i've got a
leaky roof and there's water coming in
you can think that's gonna go thousands
but um just 100 pounds
yeah really nice it's quite a light
light room isn't it yeah yeah
tell me about what the garden was like
um
and basically because it the
landlord is living abroad the previous
landlord
the tenant lived here for 40 years she
did her best to get rid of what she
could but
what she didn't want when in the garden
i want to know
the story of how you managed to buy this
so cheap
in such a booming market yeah but buying
a house like this for 60 grand
when it only needs 10 grand worth of
work and then the new value is gonna be
like about 90.
like how did you get it for 60 grand so
it was just done
advertised on right move a company
called yield it
i i saw it and i thought six you know i
think it was advertised at about
65 000 i thought you know that looks
really cheap
for a three bedroom in that area yeah
and
i saw that had a tenant in it i thought
great we'll
you know we can lift the rent still i
phoned the estate agent and they said i
found out then it was a sitting tenant
being here pre-1988 and
so they were on a protected tenancy
um so the rent was only 350 pounds a
month
but then for me it just didn't stack no
350 i mean that's
extremely low over a 60 grand house it
just doesn't stack
so then what happened so um
i left it and a few weeks later i got a
phone call from the agent
and he said um i've got news for you the
house that
you were interested in i've heard that
the tenant is moving out do you want to
see it
and i went yeah when can you fit us in
and he went today
so i went great i'll be around so
i hop-footed it round here and there was
another
couple viewing it at the time and got
straight on the phone as soon as we
walked out and put an offer in
yeah got to be so fast you know that's
the thing people
spend so long making decisions yeah i
have to think about it
yeah i have to talk to my wife and my
husband and my lawyer and my dog and
like but you were offering as you were
walking out of the door yeah that's how
fast you know
because you know you just don't want to
wait around for someone else to
move in before here's the thing though
okay you i think you've got to be
real quick at making decisions you've
been in the game a long time so you you
know that now as well but
you've also got your due diligence yeah
so what do
diligence did you do on this property
prior to
offering on it well um about seven years
ago
we sourced the property for another
landlord
which is right opposite this one and
then
we paid 56 000 pounds for it so i knew
that
60 000 pounds seven years later was a
belting deal
yeah and then also that tom you were
saying that there was others in the
street where you can see the whole
sold prices on that well how do you see
that price where do you find that
so you can check on the right move and
if you go on to um
nearby sold prices on the advert then it
will show you the houses
in the area that have sold yeah and
literally one across the street
sold about a month ago for a hundred
thousand pounds
and we actually called the agent because
we just sourced another property through
him and
he confirmed that he actually got asking
price for you
yeah nice so the 7400 you got it for 60
so cheap because there was a tenant
that's been in there for years and years
and years paying really cheap rent
and they were selling it based on the
yield yeah but then when the tenant
moved out
you gotta avoid it for sixty thousand
pounds like you're 18 years old
you've saved up ten thousand pounds
worth of hard lifetime savings
you put in ten grand then you put in
loads of time and effort entered in the
refurb
there to have a stake in a house uh 18
yeah
it's crazy and i haven't really done
anything apart from putting the money
50 grand so it's like a nice joint
venture agreement there so great keep
shopping around and see what's important
so in here i mean it was just disgusting
wallpaper
disgusting old carpet i mean we've got
photos and we have actually got a video
from from when we took the property over
and um yeah so just
get rid of it all new radiator
new light fittings new sockets
we're keeping that because it's quite a
nice feature we're going to paint that
white
and just paint it through out
how does it work so you're buying a
house for
below market value yeah and then you're
gonna spend money
on your refurb yeah bringing up the
value so you don't just want to buy it
and then bring it up
to the value that you're spending the
money on so we bought it for 60 we don't
want to spend 10 on it and then sell it
for 70.
exactly we want to buy it for 60 spend
10 on it and then we're hoping to get it
revalued at a minimum
conservatively of 85 000 which means it
will pull
most of our money out nearly all of it
yeah but we don't want to just
pull our money out and sell it we want
to
pull all the money out and rent it yes
the property
keeps going up in value and you've got a
laying engine to say so
what do you think you'll get ready for
this i think six fifty
easy six fifty six fifty what's going on
events now
they're just flying the demand is huge
that's so interesting so rent's going up
yeah
house prices didn't go up since 2006 but
now
yeah they're pushing up so crazy really
interesting market i like huddersfield
i'm getting drawn in i'm getting drawn
into here
the smallest one this was also in a bit
of a state as well i was around here
yesterday
cleaning the skirting boards uh cleaning
the upvc
windows i've done the best job that i
can but there's just some stuff that
might not go
yeah just ready so that the painters got
a nice surface to paint on because they
were so
nicotine stained i think the previous
tenant lived in here for 40 years
yeah wow what are you hoping the value
of it wouldn't you reckon
i think 85 to 90. yeah
so if it values at 85 you're gonna pull
up most of your money but leaving about
seven grand
yeah if it values at 90 you're going to
pull out pretty much all your money
yeah if it's any more than that then you
could end up
pull your money out and get some money
being paid to have a house
yeah we'll find out when the valuation
comes in but
which however which way it pans out is
much better
than saving up putting money in yeah
saving up putting money in because
you're recycling your cash flow
whatever way it works out the return on
investment is going to be great
yeah what would you say though tom
someone says well you're 18 but it's all
right for you because you've got you
know
you your mom that's wanting to join
adventure with you and
i mean what would you say to someone
that does that well i think it's just
playing with the cards that i've didn't
delve yes
i was hoping you said that yeah i think
just seizing opportunities yeah
i'm obviously in a really good position
the fact that my parents have got
experience and stuff
yeah but it's nothing unless i act on it
yeah and that's what i've been doing
saving up money to get a stake in this
house getting my rent to rent deal and
there's multiple and that's the thing
i was gonna say that it's not like
you're just going along for the ride
you've been saving up a lot of money you
spent a thousand pounds
coming on my training yeah right now
you've got a rate of rent down the road
yeah which is gonna be making you about
how much profit
and 550 pounds you've got a bit money
coming from that so you know
and the fact that i love what you said
about taking the cards you've been given
and dealing them because it's very easy
people people would always say
oh it's right for you to write to use
right views or a few but it's like hang
on a minute you weren't given any money
yes your parents were in property but so
what that's your cards
and you and you're dealing those cards
um you're also networking
yeah at the crash course yeah you were
at the crash course you wrote the crash
course
it was okay so someone who's been in
property long live of property what was
it what was the crash course like
i found it really interesting yeah
it was a good recap of quite a few
things that i knew already obviously
but just i think what it
when you work on your own in property
like i have done
for 20 years it's hard to keep yourself
motivated
yeah so i think just doing an of course
you know jumping on um clubhouse in the
morning
or you know looking at what other people
are doing
just keeps you fresh and motivated and
that's really important to me
that's so true being motivated
networking opportunities
as well yeah also some of the strategies
that i know some of the things i teach
are a little bit modern or creative yeah
should we say what did you think when
you first heard about like rent-a-ranks
and
you know just different types of
strategies and lease option agreements
well it's something that we've never
done i mean we have done lease option
agreements
before um renter rent never tried that
before so i was quite
curious is that something
is that a strategy you've been doing for
a very long time or was that new to you
i think we have but we didn't know it
was cold
so you stumbled into it yeah and then
okay
okay great great but you were a bit
worried when
tom spent a thousand pounds going on my
course
well no no i wasn't worried about that
because i just thought
if he sells one deal he can recoup
his costs so you're cool with that yeah
and also you mentioned as well like
you were thinking if you went to uni
yeah
i mean he's predicted grades of three
and three a's
and hoping he's going to come out with
an a star in one of his a-levels
yeah i'm an ex-lecturer education's
always been important in our house
and it was always always been my plan my
older daughter's at medical school
has always been my plan that he would go
to university
and but unfortunately i think i've done
too good a job
telling him about property and
explaining to him that you don't always
have to
have a job and work for someone else
yeah um
he's seen the freedom that we've had as
a family to bring up four children
yeah without working the nine to five
and i think he fancied a piece of it
so um so that's what he's gone off and
done and at first when he said i don't
think i want to go to university i'm
nervous because i didn't want him to
waste his
really good brain but
i think he's well on the way to proving
the fact that
he doesn't need to go to university yeah
he could go to university and spend nine
thousand pounds a year on fees
but he spent one thousand pounds on your
course yeah
and the results are paying off yeah like
if you got a rent to rent now
what did you when you first got the
regiment i know you were you were a
little bit worried
yeah right you're thinking i hope it
works out for you
rent something you've not done before
it's okay for me
because if i you know if i make a
mistake
i can afford to deal with it yeah if i
mess up it's on my head yeah
when it's your son who's only just
turned 18
you don't want him to fail you don't
want him to mess up yeah so
that's what concerned me i understand
that
but you knew he was in good hands yeah
you know and
we how did you feel when he started
renting the rooms out and it kind of
proved that it was working
oh so proud of him a lot more she felt a
lot more comfortable
when he actually said oh i've got two
rooms rented already within the first
week i thought oh thank goodness this is
going to work because
we haven't got an hmo in the area we
don't have any hmos that don't have
kitchenettes and non-suites
yeah so i was a bit nervous about just a
room yeah
shared everything sometimes as well you
know what you know what property
investors
sometimes people get stuck in a rut i
think yeah with their strategy and their
thing
sometimes what worked five years ago
doesn't work today so you need to be
re-educating yourself
learning new things seeing testing
things and that's what you've done
you know and you've tried you know
huddersfield really well if you've got
an election engine but you tried
something a little bit new
yeah and it's working really well i
think that's what's great about the
train and the crash course that it stays
current and it stays modern so it's
always applicable to wherever you are
yeah and yeah like my parents didn't
know about rent to rent
but because of your training they felt
assured that it was gonna work once the
room started to get rented yeah and it's
ideal for him
because you know whilst he's got a part
of this he didn't have any more money to
go
on to the next thing yeah but renter
rent he can do
and that's his baby something he can do
completely by himself and take
responsibility for
yeah and the experience not just the
money the 550 you'll make a month
but the experience from rent events
people say to me they say oh right to it
it's really risky be careful it's like
well haven't a minute you've got break
clauses
you know not what you put down a
thousand pounds into the rental round
worst case you just take such a break
clause you
lose a few grand and walk away best case
you're gonna get loads of experience
you're gonna make 550 a month you're
gonna go and get more like financial
freedom
yeah so you're just looking at best case
worst case bringing the facts
they're making a quick decision yeah
exactly what you did so you taught him
well as well
you know and you told me you feel like
you've almost got two mentors but yeah
right
you've got me yeah and then you're just
running with everything you've got yeah
definitely so what
what the plans for you the next 12
months um that's what i've set my
targets
i want to be at the financial freedom
stage as soon as possible i'm kind of
predicting that probably around
um may june time and then you you know
you're responding to come on windows on
the way to that i'll be when i'm on
windows on a wednesday
good luck yeah this time next year i
want my
passive income from property to be about
four thousand pounds a month
wow that'd be incredible yeah i think
you've got where it takes yeah i think
you've got what it takes
okay so we're tiling
um sort of up to the top of the shower
level
yeah on these two walls and then vinyl
on the floor shower to go in
bath panel to go in basin that's it
great
so i hope you enjoyed that video a lot
of golden nuggets
from tom and his mom you're going to see
tom real soon on winners on wednesday
you want to see more videos like that
check them out right here if you want to
subscribe to the channel you can do that
right here
and if you want to come to the property
investors crash course
it's free and you can do that in the
description i'll leave a link
get booked on see you soon